un match avec du rythme mais sans but
trappes n'a pas réussi à concrétiser ses
nombreuses occasions pour venir à bout
du leader boulogne billancourt sur son
terrain à l'occasion de la 11e journée
de ph
la rencontre s'est terminée par un score
nul et vierge content mais peut-être un
peu de déception aussi parce qu'on a on
a fait un match sérieux appliqué
on a poussé en deuxième mi temps on a eu
la possession du ballon les occasions
mais a malheureusement on n'a pas su
concrétiser
on se satisfait jamais d'un match nul
convient pour les victoires
cela étant il ya des matches nuls qui
valent quand même un bon résultat on
joue quand même le premier de la poule
au classement trap est actuellement dans
le ventre mou du championnat à la 9e
place mais les trappistes sont dans une
dynamique positive avec une seule
défaite en huit matches disputés
autre satisfaction l'équipe est toujours
invaincu à domicile des signes
encourageants qui promettent une
deuxième partie de saison passionnante
la baisse est de faire mieux que l'anr
on a fini quatrième donc là de chercher
un podium
on est un groupe uni soudé et je pense
qu'en faisant un peu plus passant palier
je pense que la deuxième partie de
saison pourra jouer en notre faveur on
encore du travail c'est la saison va
être super longue qu'est une poule de 14
équipes
donc on a beaucoup de choses à
travailler pour pouvoir espérer quelque
chose
la reprise pour les trappistes est
programmée pour le dimanche 8 janvier
les joueurs se déplaceront sur le
terrain de puteaux 11e du championnat
[Applaudissements]